يعني بعضها مثلا
استشارات من من بعض
صناع القرار الى الرئيس
استشارات ما فهمت يعني مثلا انه الجانب
الامريكي
[موسيقى]
سيحاول
جذب عناصر او سيحاول تقسيم العراق يعني من
خلال الموضوع المحاصصه فيجب ان يظهر مثلا
الرئيس صدام حسين الله يرحمه اذا
ظهر بخور يعني صارت جلسات المحكمه يمرر
الرسائل نصائح للشعب العراقي
وبالفعل يعني حصل هذا هل كان ذلك يتعلق
ايضا ببعض الاحداثيات للمقاومه العراقيه
ذاك موضوع اخر يعني ذاك موضوع اخر كنت
تمرر له معلومات بهذا الشان لكي يتحدث
عنها في بعض المحاكمات حتى اكون يعني صادق
بلدي محتل ومن حق اي مواطن عراقي عندما
يحتل بلده ومن حق اي مواطن يقاوم الاحتلال
بشتى الوسائل فكان يتواصل نعم مع يعني بعض
فصائل المقاومه العراقيه وهو في الاسر وهو
في الاسر نعم كان يتعامل وكانوا يستشيروه
حتى ببعض الامور يعني يطلبون عنده توجيه
كان يحصل عبرك فقط
من خلال جلسات
من خلال لقاءات ومع اخرين ايضا وتمرر له
بعض المعلومات يعني بصيغه مشفره او بصيغه
غير مفهومه يعني اغلب الامور اللي تمرر
الا بطريقه مشفره
ذلك مباشره
يعني يعرف عن ذلك يعلن عن ذلك في خلال
المحاكمات ذكي جدا هو بالجانب التشفير ذكي
جدا يعني في بعض الاحيان كان في بعض
المصطلحات اللي يستخدمها مثلا في خلال
محاكماته يكون قصدها على انها شيفره نعم
مثلا يدعوهم للصمود او يدعوهم المقاومه
واحيانا يقولها لعب بصريح العباره
قوات المسلحه المجاهده وكان القاضي نبهه
يعني كانت الامور علنيه بشكل صريح وامور
اخرى مشفره بل اعتقد انه طال ذلك ما في
مره من المرات تسميه المكان الذي اعتقد
انه فيه وكان يعتقد انه في مبنى التصنيع
العسكري هذا المكان كانوا الامريكان
الجانب الامريكي كان متوقع ان يسال الرئيس
عن المكان اللي سيحاكم فيه فالجانب
الامريكي كان هيا يعني مخادعه مع الرئيس
وللاسف يعني جعلوه يظن انه التصنيع
العسكريه
كانت مبنى مبنى القياده القوميه بس مقر
المحكمه بالتصميم العسكري